rein theoretisch ich bin in der planung
ja nicht so involviert aber in san siro
reloaded 2.0 minecraft oder so wer auf
jeden fall schon recht frech in meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zu einer weiteren folge hashtag frack
luca ich hab das ja damals schon an dich
bruder du hast dich mal diesen kleinen
sprung geschafft du solltest nicht
hochklettern einlasses du schaffst es
nicht mehr hochzuklettern man mit breit
so hell bist aber nicht mir ne dorian
mit bright falls du das sehen sollte
ich habe ja schon sehr lange kein
hashtag fragt luca video mehr gemacht
also einfach wo ich simpel ein paar
fragen beantwortet habe und dazu haltens
league gespielt habe ich habe jetzt
gesehen dass der just in dassow bei sich
eingeführt hat sondern hashtags just in
format wurde das aber nur live behandelt
die ganzen fragen ausschüsse blog ich
nehme ich will eigentlich ich will
eigentlich dings werden nicht unendlich
haider werden
ich glaube ich wäre das blog wieder
einfach nur rum rennen wo er die fragen
so beantwortet ich hab mir gedacht ich
mache das so wie weiterhin einfach musik
und wir fangen auch direkt damit der
ersten frage die mir übrigens bei
twitter stellen können twitter links in
der beschreibung der post sich auch
teilweise wenig mit jogginghose durch
die stadt laufe oder wenn bei mir im
toaster anbrennt oder so also ganz
interessante sachen die erste frage
wurde mir zugesendet von stv player fünf
könntest du mal deinen arbeitsplatz und
ein pc vorstellen hashtag fragen luca
da kann ich dir nur sagen dass ich das
in den videos bloß um meine probleme
ging also muss und meine probleme gegen
das herzig komplett falsch
da ist erstens sieger das ist stimme ich
dem nico ich glaub ich verstecke mich
einfach so richtig stimmt hier einfach
so ein holzblock debatte hier werde ich
auch weniger kanten oder muss ich mich
einstellen ich glaube ich stelle mich
sogar wo ich noch weniger erkannt werde
dahin einfach so hier doch wo bleiben da
kann ich dir nur das video empfehlen wo
ich über meine probleme rede die ich mit
meinem mischpult hatte weil da ich mein
ganzes equipment paar sie zeigen wenn du
es visuell sehen willst wenn du es
allerdings kaufen möchtest es in der
beschreibung jedes produkt verlinkt das
sind soviel eade links also ich krieg
davon dann einen minimalen prozentualen
ansatz teil ab also wenn du dir
mischpult kaust oder so über den link in
meiner beschreiben bekomme ich davon
gefühlte 23 cent kam eine halbe packung
reis cabernet also ich würde dir einfach
sagen in die beschreibung zu schauen das
eigentlich immer alles wo ich brenne ich
wenn ich's einfach in die beschreibung
schauen da ist eigentlich alles verlinkt
und ja das war zu der frage dann fragt
die jetix to go hashtag faktura wie bist
du auf die art eines schnitts gekommen
ja ich mag deine schnitt nicht nur
sondern sehr sehr xd eine ganz kurze
sache einfach zu der map
normalerweise wenn man hier unterlief
war das jedoch immer gesperrt oder
deswegen bin ich auch als sieger hier
runter gelaufen
ich glaub ich hier unten wer so dass
optimale versteckt weil man könnte sich
einfach hier hinstellen könnte
beobachten wenn einer kommt dann läuft
dann über um das auto herum ist er
wieder weg ist also ohne spaß hier kann
mich echt eigentlich nahezu niemand
finden damit ich bin da eigentlich drauf
gekommen also ich hab ja eine zeit lang
echt so wie die meisten let's play in
deutschland einfach was ja auch
eigentlich letztlich sind ungeschnitten
einfach hochladen mit man teile das
gameplay sieht aber da ich in letzter
zeit beziehungsweise schon sehr lange
keine normale let's play spam mache
sondern einfach mal so videos durch
beantworten fragen oder stelle ich mein
wort vor oder mach mal hier commands
oder so sind dass der kleine letztes wo
es wirklich notwendig ist es wirklich
notwendig ist jeden einzelnen
teilschritte zu sehen in diesem video
das heißt da kann ich einfach so was
raus hat mir da schlechte gedanken
machen zu müssen dass ich irgendwas
vorgenommen habe was
noch nicht gesehen hat von dem gameplay
deswegen hab ich mein fahrrad bio damit
ich da einfach nicht die ganze zeit 1000
machen muss auch jetzt gerade wenn ich
so neue fragen heraus suche oder so dann
schneide ich einfach ein bisschen und
dann bin ich darauf gekommen okay wie
wärs wenn ich auf eine verschachtelung
mache und meine fresse teilweise ein
bisschen größer zeige wenn irgendwas
passiert was ich witzig finde dann sucht
sich dann quasi einfach so die besten
techniken raus und ich muss echt
wirklich sagen ich bin sehr zufrieden
mit dem der ist blöd der sika ihr seht
mich nicht ändern ist der scheiße wenn
man die mal helfen
hallo mit rollerfahrers tempi lukas ort
luca seinem namen god's tempi lukas hat
jemanden gefunden wie toll ich freue
mich für dich und siehst du mich bei
pedro pro jahr
er sieht mich zieht's man sucht sich mit
der zeit selber sachen raus die man
einfach so cool findet und mir gefällt
zu schneiden und den meisten gefällt mir
auch deswegen werde ich auf jeden fall
weiter machen würdest du bei einer
zweiten longboard tour mitmachen wollen
fragt hdi also die ady ich weiß nicht
ich denke er nicht und zwar ich fahre
nicht so gerne longboard des es ja ich
gehe da lieber joggen oder mahal oder
macht irgendwas anderes ich bin da
lieber der der irgendwie in urlaub fährt
und dann lieber 30 target einander
skifahren als 30 tage beieinander
longboard fahren
vor allem weil ich deutschland als land
überhaupt nicht schön finde werden so
was allerdings irgendwie aneinander côte
d'azur gemacht werden
gotha suhl côte d'azur côte d'azur
tattoo oder also sowas wirklich
irgendwie an am meer frankreichs oder
irgendwie so daher dann dann wäre ich da
schon dann wärs mir egal was man dafür
ein sportler kann man theoretisch noch
her krabbeln dass wir einfach nur extrem
schönes ambiente aber durch deutschland
auf keinen fall wolle schreibt hashtag
fragt luca frühaufsteher oder
langschläfer und lieber zusammen mit
friends auf einer einsamen insel oder
einsam auf einer normalen insel
normale insel ist ja quasi so etwas wie
amerika oder europa oder einfach die
welt das sind ja alles normale inseln
also die frage verstehe ich nicht so
ganz aber lieber mit meinen kumpels halt
irgendwo weil alleine sein bin ich
überhaupt nicht cool und ich bin ich
weiß nicht langschläfer kann man nicht
zu definieren weil was hatte stürmer
verletzt es auch schon mal gepostet
darüber hatte ich mich mit ihm
unterhalten und zwar kann man das halt
nicht richtig definieren dass jemand zum
beispiel lange band beim an oder jemand
total faul ist und einfach total lange
im bett liegt einfach weil man nicht
weiß wer diese person ins bett gegangen
ist zum beispiel bin ich gestern einfach
habe ich von 3 uhr oder von von 2 uhr
bis 6 uhr gepennt hat einfach so vier
stunden geplant da wird man sagen sowohl
oder steht voll früh auf und so aber
geht auf prinz bett und so aber ich hab
eigentlich nur vier stunden schlafen
dann stehe ich einmal um 12 uhr auf und
alle sagen so humorvoll der langschläfer
obwohl man eigentlich auch erst um 6 und
bett gegangen hat auch eine sechs
stunden mit entweder man ist
angeschnitten hat oder feiern bei oder
so aber eigentlich bin ich echt jemand
wenn ich einfach einschlafen könnte ich
locker 14 stunden am stück schlafen und
würde mich dementsprechend als
langschläfer abstempeln michael fragt
bist du zur zeit wirklich gut drauf oder
ist das nur wegen dem image also das ist
eine sache weil ich jetzt vor ein oder
zwei tagen in diesem commands video vor
einem tag war es habe ich am ende ja
gesagt ja ich weiß nicht ob ich das noch
alles so weiter packe vielleicht hab ich
dann einfach auch mit youtube weil ich
möchte auf keinen fall aufhören zu
studieren weil ich mir das mega gefällt
was ich studiere und ich finde wenn man
spaß an etwas hat was man studiert dann
sind beste voraussetzungen
wo diese werden direkt geboxt alter also
ich hab halt gesagt dass ich eventuell
mit youtube aufhöre
aber ich muss einfach mal schauen wie
sich das in zukunft entwickelt ich meine
studie auch erst seit zweieinhalb
monaten extrem kraft aber es geht halt
alles extrem auf den schlaf ihr seht
mich ich bin immer noch mit zwei augen
hier meine meine meine augenlider liegen
mir schwer im gesicht und ich muss
schauen wie das eigentlich in snow das
eigentlich das passt eigentlich etwas
wäre das ist erfreulich vollidiot ich
würde schon sagen dass sie eigentlich
gut drauf bin nur also sie meint das
glaube ich so dass du das so meint die
bei michael
dass ich mich in den videos immer so
glücklich stelle obwohl ich gar nicht
glücklich bin
dazu kommt eventuell dazu kommt
eventuell ich weiß habe ich mich traue
sowas hochzuladen die tage so ein video
das werde ich dann nennen ich muss euch
was erzählen oder irgendwie so weit so
ein paar dinge gibt die über die ich auf
jeden fall reden möchte ohne die ich
quasi so nicht weiter youtube machen
kann
ich möchte das jetzt so nicht groß
ankündigen nur das jetzt schon mal
darauf gefasst sein dass sich da
eventuell bald das hochladen was mir
sehr am herzen
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] verein du bist du
gehst mich gesehen der victory aber ich
bin natürlich multitasking
okay okay alles geil ich laufe einfach
an euch vorbei und ich lese nehmen wir
die nächste frage von zwar stören dich
hater kommentare unter deinen video sehr
oder entfernt zu sieht in zelaya kommt
tötet mich kommt bloß die eigentlich
nicht also wenn er jetzt jemand schreibt
die kib steht ihr nicht dann denke wenn
andere beleuchtung ist ja ausgegangen
ich kriege die softbox nicht mehr an
fakt dass batterien sind alle ich
vollidiot man naja egal jedenfalls habt
ihr mich dann halt jetzt von einer seite
berichten also wenn jemand schreibt so
homann deine cap sieht voll scheiße aus
der nicht mehr einfach nur so ok lass
ich so stehen ist halt seine meinung der
juckt mich nicht weil ich das aufsätze
oder an silvas ich möchte das habe ich
ja schon mal video zum update wegen
style diese verbrenne ich mich immer
aber wenn da allerdings so kommentare
stehen wie oh das ist doch alles nur
geklaut oder so wie gesagt ich verlinke
euch das einfach mal dieses romans video
beziehe sich vor links euch nicht
sondern ich empfehle es euch das
anzuschauen da rede ich da ein bisschen
drüber über diese sache aufgeklärt oder
so am ende
deswegen das einfach anschauen auf
meinen kanal gehen quasi die von gestern
aber sonst sind mir hater eigentlich
relativ egal muss man mit leben am
besten ignorieren und die resale tv
fragt luca kannst du mal ein spontanes 1
1 timo ja machen
weil ich scheiße pvp als jetzt nicht ob
er meint dass ich das so veranstalten
soll so aufnehmen und so oder einfach
nur so aus spaß so nur spaß kann ich mir
das vorstelle aber wenig hochladen würde
möchte ich nicht hochladen glaube ich
weil ich einfach scheiß im pvp julia
schreibt unter nimmst du viel weiß ich
auch nicht so ganz was damit gemeint ist
aber ich denke jetzt mal so
freizeitaktivitäten kommen ich bin jetzt
auch mal ein bisschen produktiven
versuche ich zu den ein oder anderen
heilern hallo fünf spongebob dem jahr
also an freizeitaktivitäten waren
eigentlich schon recht viel also ich
verbringe natürlich die meiste zeit
meines lebens mit youtube und der uni
und mit essen und schlafen aber wenn
zwischendurch mal freizeit da ist gehe
ich gerne mal trainieren oder joggen
oder mit freunden halt irgendwie mal
nach spontan nach amsterdam fahren oder
irgendwie mal weil sie nicht in die
soccerhalle kartfahren schwimmbad kino
extrem oft immer wenn ich meine
heimatstadt bin gehe ich mit einer
freundin auf jeden fall manns kino weil
ich weiß nicht ich mag gute filme und
ich hab keinen bock auf kinox.to weil
ich finde gute filme da wird zu viel
geld investiert da muss man auf jeden
fall ins kino geht dieses mädchen heißt
missgeburt es war dein erstes spiel was
überhaupt gespielt hast was ich
überhaupt gespielt habe würde ich sagen
war super mario irgendwas habe ich schon
mal glaube ich gesagt aber ich weiß
nicht ob du jetzt irgendwie gaming game
einst oder einfach so spiel weil einfach
so spiel wäre ja versteckspielen keinen
boss player 9 9a hinz schreibt versteckt
radmutter wir eigentlich deine kindheit
was hast du so einen serien und so
weiter geguckt meine kindheit bestand
nicht so viele serien sondern nur aus
pokémon und judo
also sind ja serien aber ich habe die
story da nie so verfolgt sondern an doch
beim pokern habe ich die story extrem
verfolgt aber bei yu gi oh habe es nie
verstanden wird zum beispiel auch so gut
ich hatte zwar alle möglichen karten von
judy und pokémon aber ich wusste nie wie
die spiele gespielt werden so richtig
dumm ich konnte halt nur sagen ja ich
habe geld seines toten
das kann also verpacken kein plan aber
klipp fördern
an sich muss ich sagen dass meine
kindheit extrem schön
ich kann von glück reden dass ich in
keiner armen familie aufgewachsen bin
sondern auch so was solche dinge hatte
wie beispielsweise gameboy oder so womit
ich quasi auch ja zocken konnte aber ich
fand meine kindheit eigentlich an wofür
sich extrem cool und würde gerne wieder
dorthin zurück und dann fragt auch schon
der jan welchen film hast du zuletzt im
kino gesehen zuletzt im kino gesehen
habe ich welche war das deine ruhe in
frieden oder ruhet in frieden heißt er
meine ich der fand ich fand ich richtig
gut davor habe ich männer gesehen fand
ich richtig scheiße und davor habe ich
in der steller gesehen und er war auch
richtig gut hier haben wir hier zur
letzten frage die eventuell einige hier
interessieren sollte und zwar fragt der
lenovo hashtags luca welches minecraft
projekt fandest du am besten hero war
galaxy das mega projekt galaxy zählt für
mich nicht so wirklich als großes
projekt war ich da nicht so viele folgen
drin hatte war wo parteien zwar einfach
nur recht langweilig und europa 2 wenn
ich in der ersten folge gestorben also
die ideen sind extrem cool von der idee
war an sich vanille role play
das ist schon extrem geil aber mein
lieblingsprojekt ist man noch ihre und
ich muss wirklich sagen ich habe mit
vielen youtube als in letzter zeit auch
schon so drüber gesprochen
extrem viele wollen einfach so einem
minecraft hero 2.0 und ich weiß nicht
also rein theoretisch ich bin der in der
planung ja nicht so involviert aber hero
reloaded 2.0 minecraft oder so wer auf
jeden fall schon recht fresh also ich
muss wirklich sagen die hre hat mir von
allen projekten bisher am meisten
gefallen bei galaxy und vor allem beim
mega blockbuster soll zwar ganz witzig
man konnte fragen beantworten aber bei
anderen let's play an die in dem projekt
drin war vorher ja ich baue jetzt meine
zehnte space rakete und ich sag' mir
sogar leute ich hab mir wieder paar
fragen rausgesucht und bau jetzt mein
haus weiter und so also bei hero was
oder konnte man einfach entdecken und
das macht dich halt so an diesem tag
orbiteam survival mode pack weil weiß
ich nicht bei galaxy und
mega projekt war es halt so da muss man
richtig viel kraft aber bei heroes so
entdecken und so das war extrem cool
deswegen würde ich sagen meine lieben
freunde war es jetzt auch schon von
diesem video ich habe mir ein paar
fragen ausgesucht und jetzt beantwortet
wenn ihr beim nächsten mal auch dabei
sein wollte und euren namen und eure
frage hören und beantworten wollte dann
folgt mir bei twitter.com schrägstrich
contractor und stellt die frage unter
hersteller kluger und dann würde ich
sagen